Ich seh die Push-Nachricht, ein Puffo steht bereit. Mein Puls geht hoch, denn er weiss schon, was das heisst. Koch mir ein Teechen, hol die Kuscheldecke raus. Jedes Wehwehchen löst sich wie Zuckerwatte auf. Dieses Podcast-Ufo ist wie ein Schglass-Uso für meine guten Freunde. Hörer Damian, Damian, vielen, vielen Dank für diese Grosache. Die Intro hat auch einen Soundcloud-Account, könnt ihr gerne mal draufklicken, ist immer verlinkt, könnt ihr mal gucken. Ist aber privat. Ist aber auch privat gestellt. Er stellt da so Urlaubsfotos hoch und so und geht nicht drauf, lieber mal nicht. Also es ist ein bisschen unangenehm tatsächlich. Ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt, gar nicht, na wohl weiß ich nicht, weil ich bin datenschutzrechtlich nicht so gut. Und manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, das, was gerade ich angucke, von mir privat, das können alle sehen, weil das irgendwo hochgeladen ist. Und dann denke ich mir auch, aber interessiert es jemanden? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Bei mir ist es auch das große Problem, dass man irgendwann entdeckt, oh Gott, das war jetzt die ganze Zeit online, alles klar. Ich habe zum Beispiel gesehen, dass mein Ebay-Kleinanzeigenkonto, weil ich es sehr oft hier erwähnt habe, was ich alles verkaufe, sehr leicht zu finden war. Mittlerweile habe ich da mehr Follower als auf Instagram. Und man kann die nicht sehen und man kann die nicht wegmachen, man kann es nicht auf Privat stellen. Du hast doch schon einen Karrierewechsel erwogen, weil du gesagt hast, Moment mal, ich habe auf Ebay-Karriere mehr Erfolg. Ich starte jetzt da auf jeden Fall mehr Erfolg, bin auch viel erfahrener und besser und eloquenter, ehrlich gesagt. Jetzt habe ich überlegt, da eine Zweikarriere zu starten, habe es aber noch nicht, ich weiß noch nicht genau, da kann man noch keine Werbung schalten, etc. Also da ist noch ein bisschen, das ist noch in den Kinderschuhen meine Karriere. Du investierst in die Zukunft dann auf jeden Fall. Auf jeden Fall, da bin ich schon sehr gut, da habe ich jetzt Follower, allerdings und halt bei Spotify auch. Und da habe ich sehr spät erst entdeckt, dass man diesen ganzen Quatsch, den ich da höre, auch sehen kann, unter anderem live. Also was ich jetzt gerade höre und so, das war mir alles gar nicht bewusst. Ihr müsst bei Spotify dringend gucken in den Privatsphäre-Einstellungen, was ihr da eingestellt habt. Mir hat mal jemand geschickt, in so einer Chat-App hat jemand mir geschrieben so, what the fuck und dann so ein Screenshot mit Florentin Will hört gerade und dann halt die Töne-Fame das achte Mal. Musical aus den 80er Jahren, Playlist, Musicals, weibliche Hauptrollen. Ja, und da war mir erst klar, okay, gut, die kompletten Katie-Milua-Drei-Uhr-Nacht-Sessions sind alle öffentlich und können so direkt nachgeholt werden. Weil man kann ja auch immer so das hören, was der andere gerade hört und denkt sich so, Moment mal, das ist jetzt das vierzehnte Mal Folge, hatten ja auch. Jeder, den ich kennenlerne, der wird erstmal gestalkt auf Spotify. jeder mensch jeder Mensch, jedes Date, alle Menschen werden erst mal gestalkt.
Und dann hat man die Playlists Tears, Sad, Sad Tears, Happy Tears, Tears for no reason, Gym, viel Gym, viel Workout. Stimmt, zwei. Vor allem das Beste, ich glaube, das Schönste, was man über eine Person aussagen kann, ist Gym-Playlist und da sind zwei Songs drin. So angelegt, zwei drin und ein Song. Ich habe so viele Playlists, wo ein oder zwei Songs drin sind, wo man genau weiß, das sind so abgebrochene Träume. Die müsste man auch mal verkaufen, so eine Playlist Flohmarkt mal machen. Einfach mal vor die Tür stellen, auf so einem Teppich, einfach mal die ganzen Playlists raus, so jetzt müssen sie alle raus. Da kriegst du bestimmt noch 50 Cent für ein paar Playlists. Jetzt kommt bald der Muttertag. Du bist der einzige Mensch der Welt, der das auf dem Schirm hat. Ja, ich hab's jetzt im Kalender gesehen, wo das eingetragen worden ist. Und dann hab ich überlegt, die beste Idee ist eigentlich meine Spotify-Playlists. So wenig Arbeit, aber ich weiß nur, meine Mutter hört Spotify, aber Listen, wo ich nicht genau weiß, wie sie darauf kommt und was das für welche sind. Und sie wird sich niemand an den Playlist selber erstellen, aber ich denke mir, ihr eine zu machen ist so wenig Arbeit, aber glaube ich, ist ein ganz tolles Geschenk. Ist tatsächlich ein Geschenk, das bei mir schon oft funktioniert hat in romantischem Kontext, funktioniert sehr gut. Ich stelle ein allerdings Playlist zusammen, die null meinem eigenen Musikgeschmack entsprechen, ich immer denke okay das ist cool das kommt gut an das funktioniert funktioniert auch glaube ich kann das sehr gut wie viel kommt von dir wie viel kommt von dem Algorithmus von Spotify der unten die schon aus den zwei Songs die du ausgewählt hast ich sag mal so ich habe einen sehr coolen Freund der ist Fotograf und von dem nehme ich die Playlist und schicke die und sagt dann ja keine Ahnung irgendwie Fotogra generell gute, ja, so rote Fäden des Lebens. Also man kann sich an denen gut entlanghangeln, weil die haben ja, ich meine, die sind ja am Puls der Zeit, die sind ja nah, sind auch nicht die coolsten Leute, aber die sind am nächsten dran, an den coolsten Leuten. Ja, das stimmt. Und dadurch auch die Nächsten, an die wir kommen, die an coolsten Leuten dran sind. Vor allem, die verachten ja glaube ich auch oft die die Models und so und die Leute, mit denen sie abhängen. Das heißt, sie sind zwar nah dran am Puls, aber distanziert. Das heißt, sie haben genau die perfekte Einstellung zum Puls der Zeit. Oh, distanziert auch, weil er immer eine Linse zwischen denen ist und der Welt. Ist man distanzierter, wenn man immer eine Linse zwischen den Augen und der Welt hat? Ich glaube, das kann zwei Menschen auch näher bringen. Ich glaube, ja. Oh, was? Ich glaube, ein Foto, ein schönes, gutes Foto von einem Menschen ... Kommt aus Objektiv an.
Gut, da kommen wir jetzt in die Millimeter-Ecke.
Ja.
Ich glaube, ein gutes Foto von einem Menschen kann mehr so aussehen wie die Person als die Person selbst.
Da diese und mehr Aphorismen finden Sie im neuen Buch von Florentin Will.
Habe ich in Abstract gesehen.
Ach, in Abstract gesehen.
Habe ich in Abstract Staffel 1 gesehen.
Der Bestseller-Hit von Florentin Will.
Best of, Arrested Development
und Abstract Season 1.
Und Simpsons Tafeljokes.
Habe ich mal irgendwo gehört.
Spiegel Bestseller.
Habe ich mal gehört, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Nicht meine eigenen Gedanken.
Falls ihr wisst, woher, schreibt mir.
Oh, finde ich das schlecht.
Einfach nur gesammelte Gedanken, gesammelte Briefe. Gesammelte Briefe, gesammelte Mails. Mein Lieblingswitz aus ganz guter Arbeit Originals von Jonathan Kocellny, dem Wissenschaftler. Wir haben so ein paar Fake-Bücher von dem gemacht auf der Webseite und das schönste sind da gesammelte Briefe. Jonathan Kocellny, ich finde das so fantastisch. Gesammelte Briefe, Rechnungen, was halt sonst noch so anfällt. Was so anfällt. Was so anfällt. Was gerade so anfällt. Mal gucken, ich weiß nicht genau, ja, das ist für mich sehr schön. Gesammelte Briefe. So ein schamloser Typ, der einfach alles versucht zu Geld zu machen, so verschiedene Flyer, die er im Briefkasten hat. Ja, man kann sich vorstellen, das hat er entdeckt, dass er aus vielen Sachen Geld machen kann, was er vorher nicht erwartet hätte. Ich glaube, es ist keine böse Absicht bei ihm dahinter. Bei Jonathan Couchelny ist es, glaube ich, einfach nur Naivität. Das ist so eine dieser Figuren, dessen Hauptproblem ist, dass ihm niemand Nein sagt, dass er einfach veröffentlichen kann, was er will. Der hat ein sehr hochkomplexes, gut funktionierendes Team um sich herum, die aber nicht Nein sagen. Das war immer die Prämisse für uns. Zu wenig gefiltert einfach. Ja, das war eine Sketch-Reihe, wo es um Wissenschaftssendungsparodien geht. Und diese Hauptfigur, so ein bisschen so eine Carl Sagan-artige Figur, die, oder wie Rangel Jogisch war, geht jetzt so ein bisschen naiv durchs Leben, aber hat, das war immer die Prämisse beim Schreiben für uns, hat nie jemanden, der Nein sagt. Nee. Er hat kein Korrektiv im Team, aber ein sehr gutes Team. Genau, und er hat, wahrscheinlich kann man sich das so vorstellen, er hat, das war immer die Prämisse beim Schreiben für uns, hat nie jemanden, der Nein sagt. Er hat kein Korrektiv im Team, aber ein sehr gutes Team. Genau, und er hat, wahrscheinlich kann man sich das so vorstellen, er hat so viel Geld, dass er seinen Leuten so viel zahlen kann, dass die keine Wiederrede geben und auch völlig unemotionalen Jobs sind. Die haben einen guten Job, die haben gute Arbeitszeiten, die haben mehr Urlaubstage, glaube ich, weiß ich nicht. Und niemand weiß, woher er das Geld hat, das ist auch so mysteriös. Und deswegen kann er auch alle Bücher veröffentlichen, weil er einfach irgendwie total wenig Anteile will und so. Also wenn es mit guter Arbeit weitergeht, dann würde ich mal irgendwann so einen Enthüllungsbericht machen über Hinojohn-Cocellny, weil da sind mittlerweile ein paar Sachen ans Licht gekommen. Böse Geschichten. Ich habe Little Women gesehen am Wochenende. Ich habe immer Little Women gesagt. Ja. Und alle haben sich mal geboten und gedacht, was ist das für ein lustiger Film, Little Woman, weil Little Women heißt es natürlich. Little Women, so wie hieß diese kleine Maus? Stuart Little! Stuart Little. Ist das der zweite Teil? Das einzige, was gemeinsam hat, ist das Wort Little im Titel. Aber kann man so eine Reihe machen? Ich sage einen Filmtitel und du musst einen neuen Filmtitel sagen, der das letzte Wort als erstes Wort hat. Okay, Stuart Little. Little Miss Sunshine. Eternal Sunshine? Nein. Ja. Nee, du könntest aber Sunshine sagen. Sunshine, der Film? Guter Film. Ist das nicht der, der mit dem von Inception? Ja, jetzt nochmal der mit diesem wehren Gesicht, der auch Scarecrow. Ach so, da heisst du eigentlich nicht, keine Ahnung. Kelly Murphy, der spielt glaube ich in Sunshine mit. Toller Film. Der hat doch Spaß gemacht, oder? Ja, und jetzt ist vorbei, weil Sunshine hat nur ein Wort. Jetzt dreht sich im Kreis, für immer. Wir sind für immer in diesem Limbo gefangen, auf jeden Fall. Oh Gott. Und aber mega verwirrender Film, ehrlich gesagt, weil der ist ja so total emotional, irgendwie so verschiedene Frauen, die versuchen sich zu verwirklichen, irgendwie Emma Watson, alle dabei, und ganz, ganz fantastisch, Meryl Streep, und, aber mega weirdes Ende. Das Ende war so weird und war so ein Mindfuck für mich, jetzt spoiler ich für ganz viele, ich spoilere, ich sag nicht, was passiert, aber ich sag das, was passiert, was oft auch schon ein Spoiler ist, und ich konnte den Film gar nicht emotional ausklingen lassen, weil ich so verwirrt war, weil der plötzlich so eine weirde Metaebene aufgemacht hat und sich selbst kommentiert hat und man das bei so einem Film überhaupt nicht erwartet, das ist so dieser klassische Historiendrama, der schöne Prinz kann sich nicht entscheiden, welche Frau er heiratet und hochemotional und am Ende guckt er dann in die Kamera und sagt, na, das habt ihr euch wohl anders vorgestellt und holt irgendwie eine moderne Fernbedienung raus und spult den Film zurück. So auf dem Niveau, ein bisschen, war dieser Mindfuck. Was ist denn jetzt los? Und du hast plötzlich so diesen Park und alles so und dann kommen die Pferde und dann, oh, Sir Montgomery, ich muss mich noch mal erkundigen. Und plötzlich zoomt die Kamera raus und man sieht, dass es nur ein Filmset ist. Filmteam. Eigentlich alles ist in so einer Halbkugel, so einer Schneekugel drin, von so einem kleinen Kind, der das schüttelt, zu Hause, irgendwie in der Zukunft, mit so einer Laserbrille auf dem Kopf. Und die Kamera zoomt noch weiter raus. Wir sehen, dass es ein grosser Spielplatz ist. Ich habe noch nie eine bessere Werbung für einen Film gehört. Ehrlich gesagt, ohne Scheiss, das sind moderne Trailer. Ich wette mit euch, das sind moderne Trailer. Einfach ein Typ, dem man vertraut, mit seinem Filmgeschmack, der einem sagt, ihr glaubt nicht, was am Ende passiert ist. Ich will jetzt nicht verraten, was passiert, ich sag nur das in der Art, was passiert. Und dann fängst du an, irgendwie so ein weird, weil selbst wenn es nicht passiert, will ich mir diesen Film jetzt anschauen. Ich fand es super strange und ich konnte, ich habe es nicht gecheckt und das ist so ein Film, wo man erst mal googeln muss, bevor man dann so das ist so, Filme bauen ja so eine emotionale Spannung auf und oft ist das Ende dann so ein Loslassen und dann so ein, ah, okay. Aber manche Filme, ich bin manchmal für Filme zu dumm, diese Entspannung zu kriegen und check mich so, wer ist jetzt gestorben am Ende, was, wer hat jetzt wenig und was? Ach, das war der vom Anfang. Und dann musste ich erst googeln und habe währenddessen diesen Entspannungsbogen in mir aufrecht und google und lese Wikipedia und dann so, ach das war der Bruder, ich dachte das war der Vater, so. Ah, okay. Achso ja dann. Und dann. Aber man ist so ein bisschen unentspannt, weil man ist nach wie vor, du kommst ja nicht zu der Entspannung der Film, die er mitgeben sollte eigentlich.
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Sondern du bist dann noch so, über den Abend hin klingt es so aus und du liegst noch im Bett mit offenen Augen, startest an die Decke und überlegst noch ein bisschen.
Vor allem das ist eigentlich die schlimmste, ich meine so ein Film kostet wahnsinnig viel Geld, wahnsinnig viel Talent, über ein Jahr lang hinweg arbeiten und dann ist die Reaktion, ach so ja dann.
Ja, das ist es dann halt. Guck mal in der Folge Family Guy. Das ist die schlimmste Reaktion auf einen Film, die man haben kann. Ach so. Ja. Chip. Ach so. Und dann zoomt man raus und sieht das, und dann Close-Up auf den Chip und man zoomt raus und sieht, dass es eigentlich die Wüste ist. Und in der Wüste so ein kleines Kamel sieht man dann, dass es so durchgeht und man zoomt noch weiter raus und man sieht, die Wüste war die ganze Zeit nur ein Sandkasten, wo so ein kleines Kind drin ist. Und wir zoomen rein in die Augen des Kindes und dann sehen wir in der Pupille plötzlich das Universum, ein Raumschiff fliegt vorbei, aber das Raumschiff ist aus Plastik und wir sehen, es ist eigentlich Plastikmüll im Ozean.
Ja genau und dann zoomen wir raus und dann kommen die Credits schon, nach drei Minuten Film. Raumschiff fliegt vorbei, aber das Raumschiff ist aus Plastik und wir sehen, es ist eigentlich Plastikmüll im Ozean.
Ja, genau. Und dann zoomen wir raus und dann
kommen die Credits schon, nach drei Minuten Film
und dann wird es nur noch wehrer. Ja, genau.
Dann kommen die Credits, dann kommen die Credits,
dann kommt der Film, dann kommt Akt drei.
Die Credits kommen von rechts nach links
und man dreht sich dann im Kreis,
das ist ein 360-Grad-Film, die
Kinositze fahren ruckartig
zwei Meter nach oben. Ja, in zwei Stockwerke nach oben, wo Little Women läuft. Genau, dann kommt dieses Eis an der Kasse Bild, das Licht geht nochmal an, man kann sich nochmal ein Eis holen. Man kann sich Eis holen und suppen, warme Suppen. Und in dem Moment, in dem alle den Saal verlassen haben, zack geht's weiter, 3D-Brillen plötzlich, 3D-Video, Wasser spritzt. 3D-Brillen, aber alles funktioniert nicht, weil die Drehbrillen müssen viel so schnell ausgehändigt werden, funktioniert nicht, werden auch nicht draufgeworfen. Das Publikum wird beschmissen mit 3D-Brillen, Wasser kommt von der Decke, weil es ja 4D-Experience. Über den gesamten Film steht, jetzt können sie ihre 3D-Bilder aufsetzen, im Mitte des Bildschirms, es gibt keine 3D-Bilden. Im ganzen Kino nicht, keine einzige.
Alles Buchen unter ihren Sitzen hat nicht geklappt,
wurde nicht nachgefüllt.
Oh mein Gott.
Hängt das Eis? Hot Dogs!
Es ist nicht ein Weiderfilm.
Ja, aber
Empfehlung oder Nachricht
unentschlossen? Ich würde sagen,
drei von sieben Popcorn-Tüten und ja, geht rein, wenn ihr Popcorn mögt, ansonsten guckt was anderes an. Ja, ich bin gespannt, ich habe jetzt Bock auf den Film. Ich habe gerade, bevor ich hergekommen bin, an manchen Stellen meine Haut brennt es gerade, bin ich ganz ehrlich, weil ich habe Abflussreiniger.
Also ich bin da umgezogen und die neue Wohnung war die Dusche. Oh Mann, du wirst doch sterben in dieser Wohnung. Wir wissen doch beide. Wir hatten schon den Strom, habe ich den Stromschlag schon? Ja, habe ich schon. Ja, haben wir schon. Genau, und dann war in der Dusche, lief das über das Wasser, man lief nicht richtig ab, deshalb habe ich mal Abflussreiniger reingegossen. Und ja, ich bin aber ganz ehrlich, da stehen da ganz viele Warnungen drauf und ätzend und super ätzend und tötet alle Tiere im Umkreis von drei Kilometern. Diese Warnungen sehe ich, aber es ist etwas, was man im Supermarkt kaufen kann, für jeden Vollidioten zu kaufen. Ich nehme und dann hast du eine lustige orangene Verpackung und dann ist da irgendwie so ein Blitzblank-Zeichen drauf und irgendwie getestet. Und man denkt die ganze Zeit, das kann ja nicht so gefährlich sein. Was ich im Rewe kaufen kann, kann nicht so gefährlich sein. Absolut. Ich weiß sowas wie, man soll es nicht trinken, mache ich auch nicht. Man soll keine Spültaps essen, mache ich auch nicht. So doofe Sachen mache ich nicht, aber wenn man das mit der Hand berührt, gehen sie auf jeden Fall zum Arzt. Sorry, wer macht das denn? Ich denke mir auch, das muss so gemacht sein, dass man es auch essen könnte. Ja. Selbst wenn da nicht Essen draufsteht. Ja, wirklich. Das ist auch für jeden Vollidioten gemacht. Ja. Genau wie ich, der einen Gasgriller aufgebaut hat, denke ich mir auch, so gefährlich kann es ja da nicht sein. Ja. Habe ich Angst, dass ich einen Grasglauch vorbeigehe? Ja, natürlich. Ja, ja. Weil da offene Leitungen jetzt rumliegen und Gas und so, aber ich habe es da bauen dürfen. Das System funktioniert doch. Ich bin Teil der Kette. Eine Kette, in der ich Teil bin, die muss vorher Bulletproof sein. Es gibt dümmere Menschen als mich. Ich habe schon mal jemanden kennengelernt in der 11. Klasse, der war deutlich dümmer als ich. Und der könnte es auch kaufen. Der könnte es kaufen und der
könnte es essen. Und so dumme Leute
haben es in der Vergangenheit schon gekauft.
Die Firma ist nicht verklagt worden,
ist nicht weitergegangen. Und Person,
die Saison lebt auch noch. Ja, von daher
was kann mir passieren. Zwar im Wachkoma,
aber gut. Gut.
Weil die sich das in die Augen gesprüht hat,
das Raid, Insektenspray.
Nicht giftig. Ach, was sollst du, erst mal so unter das Zahnfleisch schmieren, einfach so hinter die Hüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüüünen? Ich denke mir auch immer so, ich würde das auch machen, erster Tag irgendwie Kommissar Drogenfahndung, erster Tag Koks, ist das Koks, schmierst du mir hinter die Zähne und dann ... Wie soll das schmecken, wenn es Koks ist? Ich glaube, es soll betäuben. Aber warum will man das Zahnfleisch betäuben? Machen das Leute mit Zahnschmerzen? Habe ich mich dann gefragt. Aber ist dann so, es wird verhaftet, sie haben das Recht, auf einmal zu schweigen. Bitte was? Was für Recht habe ich? Kann gegen sie verwendet werden. Was kann gegen mich verwendet werden? Kann ich noch ein bisschen Speed mir unter die... Alles, was sie sagen, kann gegen sie verwendet werden. Bitte was? Alles, was sie sagen, kann gegen sie verwendet werden. Sie dürfen jetzt ihre Hände hochnehmen. Kann ich nicht noch Ritalin geben oder so? Hey, Macarena, verhaftet. Aber ich glaube, das ist echt ein Problem. Aber ich nehme mal an, du hast es überlebt, was passiert ist? Ja, ich habe es überlebt. Meine Nase wirkt leicht weggeätzt, weil ich habe mich danach an die Nase gefasst. Hätte ich machen sollen vielleicht. Und der Ausguss war voller Haare von fremden Menschen, die da vorhin in der Wohnung gewohnt haben. Das war ein bisschen eklig, ehrlich gesagt. Ich ekele mich nicht so doll, aber bei sowas habe ich mich gerade sehr geekelt. Doch, doch. Aber das muss man auch mal hinter sich kommen, muss man was hinter sich bringen, sowas. Ja, ich finde es gut, dass wir, glaube ich, offiziell die nächste Phase von Stefan Tietze angefangen haben. Der Heimwerker-Tietze, der, naja, mit einem Bein im Grab-Tietze, der, was kommt als nächstes Tietze, der, ich habe mir jetzt so eine Glasschleifmaschine gekauft und damit mich skalpiert ausgesehen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Jede Woche komme ich hier rein und denke mir, na,
ist die Augenklappe schon da? Es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn er nicht hier säße, auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe jetzt schon
einen eigenen Beistelltisch gebastelt.
Das muss man sagen, ja.
Aus Materialien, die man an den Baumark kaufen konnte, habe ich das gemacht.
Das war wirklich sehr nervenaufreibend,
hat aber gut funktioniert, ist eigentlich ganz schön geworden. Toll. Ein Spiegeltisch. Vielleicht kann ich da malt kaufen konnte, habe ich das gemacht. Das war wirklich sehr nervenaufreibend, hat aber gut funktioniert. Eigentlich ganz schön geworden.
Toll. Ein Spiegeltisch. Vielleicht kann ich da mal
das Rezept, hätte ich was gesagt.
Moment, Spiegeltisch? Ein Spiegeltisch.
Du siehst dich selbst. Ja, na ja,
du guckst ja von oben schräg drauf, du siehst
dich selbst, siehst den Boden nochmal.
Der passt in jede Wohnung. Den Boden? Na ja,
das ist ein Tisch, der nur aus Spiegeln
besteht. Oben ist ein Kubus aus Spiegeln.
Ach so, okay. Nur Spiegel, sieht fantastisch aus, weil auch in jeder Wohnung sieht er fantastisch aus, per Definition, weil es ein Spiegeltisch ist, der die Farbe des Raumes aufgreift, auf die natürlichste Art und Weise. Wie funktioniert ein Spiegel? Das hatten wir schon so oft. Und jeder schickt uns immer dieses eine Scheißgift, wo man sieht, dass jemand irgendeine Flüssigkeit auf irgendwas giesst und dann ist es in Spiegel. Ja, aber was ist die Flüssigkeit?
Ich habe auch neulich gedacht, vielleicht reden wir zu häufig das gleiche Zeug.
Aber Leute, das ist Folge 1000 vom Podcast UFO.
Übrigens, herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Danke.
Also da muss man doch mal irgendwann, sagt man halt Dinge, man weiß nicht mehr alles, was passiert ist.
Das hat nichts mit Faulheit zu tun, das ist Dummheit.
Ja, das ist reine Dummheit. Wir vergessen es halt einfach. Ja. allem, ihr habt besseres Gedächtnis als wir, bewiesenermaßen. Ja, weil ihr die Puffepilie habt. Ja gut, das stimmt, das ist eine gute Seite. Das ist eine gute Seite. Jedenfalls, das würde mich wirklich nicht wundern, wenn ich bald im Grab liege. Es ist gefährlich und die meisten Unfälle passieren zu Hause, das muss man auch mal ganz ehrlich sagen. Ja stimmt, was wird passieren? Also angenommengenommen, wäre es jetzt nicht hier und dann... Wahrscheinlich wäre ich in eine offene Leitung gefasst. Also Strom, die Top drei Gründe, warum ich nicht mehr hier säße, Platz 1 ist Strom, Platz 2 Sturz, Leitersturz, ich habe das ein bisschen zweigeschössig, Sturz, Platz drei, Chemikalie. Definitiv. Wie würde ich das an mich herangeraten, dass du tot bist? Ja, gute Frage. Das freut mich generell. Ich glaube, du würdest mich vermissen. Also du würdest erst mal, nee, ich meine jetzt nicht emotional, sondern du würdest merken, es kommen keine Antworten mehr. Auf meine Witzchen. Auf deine Witzchen. Da kommt kein ha ha ha hi hi hi. Auf die nächsten Termine. Wenn du sagst, wann nehmen wir nächste Woche auf, morgen, kannst du morgen, kommt keine Antwort. Dann nehme ich alleine auf. Ich glaube, ich würde erst so sieben Folgen alleine aufnehmen, wobei ich immer sage, wo war der eigentlich mit dieser Stäben, wie war der nochmal? Stäslinger, was war der nochmal? Aber ich bin absolut deiner Meinung, ich glaube, Dinge sind nicht gefährlich. Ich habe mir jetzt auch das erste Mal in meinem Leben Mundspülung, Mundwasser gekauft. Da steht auch drauf, nicht trinken. Und ich denke, pfff. Klar trinke ich das. Natürlich. Ich mache es in meinem Mund. Was war das, was ich damit mache? Vor allem, als ob man in Deutschland irgendwas kaufen könnte, was dazu gedacht ist, in seinen Mund zu tun, was man dann aber nicht schlucken darf, dann stirbt man sofort. Vergiss es. Ich habe zu viel Vertrauen in das Land, in Deutschland, in die deutschen Behörden. Vielleicht ist es, wenn ich irgendwo anders aufgebrochen bin, wäre es anders, aber vielleicht ist es auch gefährlich. Es ist viel zu gefährlich, glaube ich, dass wir beide so viel Vertrauen darin haben. Vor allem, es ist ja dafür gemacht, dass alles in dem Mund stirbt. Dann schluckt man das runter und dann stirbt auch alles, was in dem Magen ist. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es nicht gut, wenn alles in deinem Magen stirbt oder tüttet es wertvolle Darmbakterien. Ich weiß es nicht. Man weiss nicht, wie die das auswählen, was stirbt und was nicht. Ja, genau. Aber ich bin komplett deiner Meinung, was in den Mund kommt. Wenn du gurgelst ja auch, da kommt ja immer ein bisschen was. Ey, das macht so viel Spaß, das Gurgeln. vor allem, ich weiss nicht, ob das die Idee ist, aber ich bin da komplett deiner Meinung, was in den Mund kommt, wenn du gurgelst ja auch, da kommt dir immer ein bisschen was.
Ey, das macht so viel Spaß, das Gurgeln vor allem, ich weiss nicht, ob das die Idee ist, aber ich gurgel dieses Mundzeug und dann entstehen aber so ganz viele Blubberblasen oben auf meinem Mund. Und du lachst dich kaputt, verschluckst dich. Ich lach mich kaputt, verschluckst dich, schlag mit dem Hinterkopf gegen die Badewanne, fahre ihn und mach's nochmal. Und ich habe dann wirklich so ganz viele Blubberbläschen, mein Mund ist wie so ein Berg, türmt sich so auf und ich fühle mich wie Schiggy immer, weil wenn du sagst Schiggy mit Blubber, ich dachte immer mal, Schaggy ist es. Der Imitator mit Rechtschreibschwäche, Stefan Tietze. Nein, Moment, ganz kurz. Shaggy.
Shaggy? Shaggy. Nee, wie nimm ich Shaggy? Shaggy! Ja, aber hat einen ähnlichen Shaggy-Ansatz. Ich weiß nicht, ob die verwandt sind. Shaggy! Shaggy! Sind die verwandt? Ich weiß nicht. Shaggy! Was ist das für ein Familientreffen? Weihnachten, Shaggy und Shaggy sitzen am Tisch. Was haben die sich zu sagen? Bei den Shaggy's. Immer noch kein Schillock. Die Mutter ist enttäuscht. Mutter ist mega enttäuscht. Bruder ist schon lange in Schillock. Bruder spielt Football auf Stipendium als Schillock. Shaggy hat immer noch keine Freundin. Shaggy versuchst mit Mondsteinen schon seit Jahren, aber da geht nix. Niemand weiß, was nach Shaggy kommt. Shiggy, Shillock, Shaggy. Das ist dann mal eine Sitcom, oder? Shiggy, Shillock, Turtalk und Shaggy. Zusammen mit der WG. Die Weiterentwicklung von Shaggy ist Sean Paul. Ah, sehr gut. Turtalk, dann, Klassik.
Stell dir mal vor, jetzt würde angekündigt werden, Netflix 2021, die Pokémon-Serien, alle, yes, die Pokémon-Serie.
Und da wurde irgendein ganz wilder Typ mitbeauftragt, der gesagt hat, nee, das ist eine Sitcom mit Shaggy und Shaggy und Sherlock und irgendwie Missy Elliott hat einen Gastauftritt.
Das ist ultra weird.
Shaggy, Shaggy, Sherlock, Tupac.
Ah, ist alles ganz merkwürdig und alle Pokémon, also null Humor für Pokémon-Fans.
Der ist ein Drehbemrouter, der mir im Briefing so halb zugehört hat.
Ja, genau, der so erst Monate später erfahren hat, dass es was mit Pokémon zu tun hat.
Und davor schon diese...
Fuck, fuck, fuck, Deadline, Deadline, Deadline.
Tupac.
Shaggy, Sherlock, Tupac. Ach ja, das wäre eine gute Serie. Ich glaube eh, dass alle Serien, die jetzt produziert werden, sagen, okay, wir haben nicht genug Leute, lass uns einfach alle Projekte zusammenwerfen. Wir machen alles zusammen, werfen alles in einen Topf und dann hast du so diese Serie, wo alles drin ist. Bei Avengers Endgame ja auch funktioniert mässig, wir werfen alles in einen Topf. Alles zusammenkloppen. Crossover-Episoden sind eh die besten eigentlich. Ich habe die Tage ja immer so einen Tweet rausgehauen, weil ich das einfach mehr aus Archivgründen, weil ich es nach wie vor toll finde. Die Vorstellung, dass man das Superhelden-Franchise, meinetwegen auch Marvel, erweitert um Wissenschaftler. Werner Röntgen. Ich will gerne die Origins, weil es ist ja, Superhelden und Wissenschaftler sind ja sehr weit beieinander. Bruce Wayne ist ja nichts anderes als ein Wissenschaftler. Batman ist ein Wissenschaftler. Ja, Iron Man ist ja auch nichts anderes als ein Wissenschaftler. Aber jetzt so jemand wie Albert Einstein,
so Doktor Strange-mäßig zu erzählen,
wie er so Portale aufbauen kann und durch die Raumzeit wandeln kann,
mit seiner lustigen Zunge, die er immer rausstreckt.
Man kennt ja, das ist ja bestimmt ein lustiger Kerl gewesen.
Dann Werner Röntgen, der die Röntgenstrahlung alle fertig macht und mittlerweile noch so ein blaues blitzendes Skelett ist,
was hinten am Horizont auftaucht.
Finde ich fantastisch.
Dann irgendwie Mannheim erzählen, 1800 noch was, wo dann Werner Röntgen gelebt hat. Finde ich ganz toll. Das ist eine gute Idee. Tesla mit seinem krassen Blitzen. Da gibt es bestimmt schon eine Serie, Tesla. Tesla hat ja diese abgefahrene Tesla-Coil erfunden, die man immer nachgebaut hat, irgendwie so ein YouTuber, was aussieht wie eine Waffe, wie so eine Ghostbusters-Waffe, wo vorne halt diese krassen Tesla-Blitze rauskommen. Versprichst du mir, dass du mir das nicht nachbaust, Stefan? Ich bin gerade in der Heimwerker-Phase. Du hast keine Volt, nicht über fünf Volt diese Woche. Tooltime, Stefan. Strom, Stefan im Grunde. Strom, Stefan. Das ist einfach ACDC-Stefan. Stefan Strom, ich hätte auch gerne diese Bauchtasche. Stefan Strom. Stefan Strom. Der langweiligste Superheld aller Zeiten. Hier ist Elektro, Bronny und Stefan Strom. Bsspp. Und Markus Mann, einfach Mann. Thomas Mann. Thomas Mann. Einfach dabei. Nee, aber ich finde, ja, also Wissenschaftler finde ich toll. Da würde ich gerne mal so ein ... Edison vs. Tesla muss ich anfangen.
So wie Superman vs. Batman, aber Edison vs. Tesla.
Gleichstrom vs. Wechselstrom.
Da bin ich so krasse Maschinen.
Im Prinzip ist es Prestige, der Film Prestige.
Nur mit Albert Einstein und Werner Röntgen.
Werner Herzog.
Thomas Mann. Werner Heisenberg. Die drei Werners.
Alle Werners.
Das ist auch in der nächste Sitcom.
Die Werners.
Der Brösel Werner, Werner Herzog, Werner Heisenberg, die drei Werners. Alle Werners. Das ist auch in der nächste Sitcom, die Werners. Der Brösel Werner, Werner Herzog, Werner Heisenberg.
Ja, und dann kommt Da Vinci, am Ende kommt so ein Riesenkrieg, alle Wissenschaftler laufen in die anderen Wissenschaftler und dann kommt so Da Vinci, fliegt oben, stürzt aber ab, natürlich, weil das ein Vollidiot ist, stürzt mit seiner Drecksmaschine ab und keiner der beiden Seiten will Da Vinci in seinem Team haben.
Welcher Vorname hat die besten Leute? Welcher Vorname hat die besten Leute?
Ja, Werner ist schon ganz oben mit dabei. Werner? Aber negative Leute werden wieder abgezogen.
Johann, Johannes, der Wortstamm Jo.
Katrin? Welche Katrin?
Bauerfeind?
Du kennst eine Katrin. Schwierig zu sagen, aber es gibt auch bestimmt Umfragen, so Studien, welcher Vorname ist der, weil es gibt auch so, dass grosse Leute erfolgreich sind als kleine, aber dann gibt es bestimmt auch so Studien, was der erfolgreichste von. Es gibt doch bestimmt so High-Energy-Eltern, die gesagt haben, welcher Vorname ist mir egal, ich will den Namen der meisten Erfolg bringt einfach. Genau. Grosszüchten, immer auf die Streckbank. Ist halt die Frage, ich finde Vornamen passen immer auch zu Menschen. Das ist eine seltsame Erkenntnis, aber Vornamen passen immer zu Menschen. Ich kenne keinen, wo der Vorname nicht passt. Und ich weiss nicht, weil werden die Menschen zum Vornamen, werden die Vornamen zu den Menschen im Kopf bei einem, produziert man da so viel rein, dass man es irgendwann, oder verbindet man das eh die ganze Zeit schon von Anfang an. Jetzt haben wir schon die nächste Gameshow. Du kriegst sechs Leute vorgeführt, und die haben jeweils, das sind jeweils drei Paare mit demselben Vornamen. Und du musst am Ende dieser zweieinhalbstündigen Show,
in der, da gibt es dann Tischtennis und Waffeln backen und so,
halt, man muss halt irgendwie die zweieinhalbstündigen.
Peter Maffay singt.
Wir haben relativ viele Musikerks tatsächlich,
aber es ist eigentlich mehr eine Musikkonzertshow.
Es ist eine Musikshow.
Aber dieses mit dem Vornamenraten ist auch noch so. Aber in Sengler erinnert sich niemand mehr an die Vornamensache. Ja, und am Ende musst du dann als Stefan Strom, du hast so ein Blitzoutfit an, und musst dann sagen, ja, ich glaube, ihr beiden habt den selben Vornamen, nee. Ja, dann aber ihr beiden, nee. Nee. Aber ihr beiden, ja. Das war's bis nächste Woche. Aber der Vornehmann wird auch nicht gesagt, ne, dann. Das wäre ja auch lustig. Ich finde auch Quizshows lustig, wo die richtigen Antworten nie gesagt werden. Oh, das ist so fies. Es macht keinen Sinn. Das macht natürlich keinen Sinn, weil du willst ja auch um dich ein bisschen zu bilden. Schön zu Hause mitraten und dann aber keine Chance. Oder wo die Frage und die Antwort sehen nur die Kandidaten. Die Frage hören nur die Kandidaten. Genau. Die Antworten sehen alle. Werner Röntgen. Falsch. Einfach so den Zuschauer möglichst weit ausklammern. Aber ich glaube, die Leute werden zugucken und denken, was ist die Frage? Auf welche Frage war Werner Röntgen die falsche Antwort? Ich weiss weder die Frage noch die Antwort. Noch fällt mir eine Frage ein, wo es die richtige Antwort wäre. Ich glaube, die Leute würden dranbleiben. Genau, weil ich glaube, die Fernsehmacher, also die Fernsehmacher hört mal kurz zu, denken die ganze Zeit falsch. Es ist so sehr, Fernsehen ist gerade so sehr inklusiv. Man versucht den Zuschauer reinzuholen, wie bist du umarmen. Ich glaube, mittlerweile will der, es ist wie in der, wenn man halt so auf jemanden steht, dann will man die, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, man will, muss sich rar machen. Man muss natürlich auch ein bisschen dann sie kommen lassen, man muss mit seinen Reizen sparen. Man darf nicht alles sofort alles raushauen. Es ist ja auch in diesem bligen Datingbuch steht auch drin, dass man auch mal teasen soll und gemein sein soll. Das sind diese furchtbaren Sachen. Aber was ich damit meine ist, wenn man das mal anwendet auf die Fernsehlandschaft, dann muss man auch eine Fernsehsendung vielleicht auch mal den Zuschauer ein bisschen abweisen, damit der Zuschauer diese Sendung umso mehr will. Oder so auch die, der Zuschauer, die Kamera sieht auch nur so die Hälfte von dem Kandidaten und die Kamera fährt so langsam weg während der, während der Show, sodass man am Ende gar nichts mehr sieht. Am Anfang hat man noch so ein bisschen was. Es beginnt als Quizshow und endet in einer Kochshow nebenan. Ja, wo wir gerade bei Spielideen sind, ich habe noch eine geniale Spielidee, die ist so genial, ich habe Angst, die hier zu sagen, weil ich habe Angst, dass die mir geklaut wird. Und zwar folgendes, pass auf.
Das ist eine ganz neue Paranoia, die du entwickelt, mit deinen scheiß App-Ideen und Spielideen.
Pass auf, du spielst gegen sechs Leute, die siehst du nicht, du chattest mit denen, du chattest mit sechs Leuten.
Fünf davon sind eine KI, Einer ist der Gegenspieler, Bernd. So, und jetzt stellst du eine Frage an alle sechs, wie zum Beispiel, was ist Liebe? Und die KIs antworten, jeder für sich, und Bernd muss auch antworten, aber Bernd muss so antworten, dass du nicht merkst, dass er keine KI ist. Also Bernd muss sozusagen, es ist so der Anti-Turing-Test, man muss so tun, als wäre man eine KI. Und du musst die rauswerfen, von dem du denkst, dass es ein echter Mensch ist. Und je früher Bernd rausfliegt, desto mehr Punkte kriegst du. Dann geht's andersrum.
Du musst ja rausfinden, wer Bernd ist.
Du musst rausfinden, welcher der sechs, also sie können dann lustige Tiere sein, irgendwie so ein Fuchs mit so einem witzigen Hut auf oder so ein Kaninchen, das an so einem Baum hängt oder so ein Faultier in so einer Hängematte oder vielleicht so ein, dass man auch so mit den Erwartungen spielt, so der dicke Elefant, aber der hüpft dann auf einem Trampolin oder so und macht dann so ein witziges Gesicht oder so oder halt keine Ahnung, so ein Nashorn, das dann total schwach ist oder so, dass irgendwie dann die Tür nicht aufkriegt und halt irgendwas. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Wir verstehen die Idee. Oder vielleicht so ein Pinguin, der friert oder so. Kann man da auch so zu zweit spielen. Warte, aber so ein Pinguin, so ein Schal, der dann sagt, können wir die Klimaanlage vielleicht ein bisschen ausmachen. Ich bin es ein bisschen frisch hier. Einfach, um noch so eine andere Ebene reinzubringen. Und dann sagst du, was ist Liebe? Und dann kriegst du sechs Antworten und sagst du, nee, das Nashorn schmeiße ich raus. Ich glaube, das ist ein echter Mensch. Auch weil ich das Nashorn nicht mag. Genau. Auch weil ich den Pinguin liebe. Genau, du kannst so ein bisschen mitspielen. Und dann fliegt das Nashorn raus und dann, oh, ist es Bernd oder nicht? Mäh, nein, es war nicht Bernd. Und dann Bernd, wir sehen Bernd auf der anderen Seite der Schattenwand. Darf sich aber nicht zu sehr freuen, weil sonst siehst du ja das erst. Aber dann hat man keine Lust mehr, dann muss man die Schattenwand wieder einräumen, wie man das kennt. Und man kriegt die nicht so gefaltet, wie vorher im Paket gefaltet war, und dann liegt das so wie bei Sagerland. Niemand hat Sagerland wieder verpacken können danach. Es ist primär eine Fernsehsendung, aber wenn du da auch keine Lust mehr hast, dann kannst du schon früher auf. Also, ich erkläre Ihnen die Regeln, Herr Tietze, ich erkläre Ihnen die Regeln, wenn Sie es schaffen, Bernd in den ersten drei Versuchen rauszunehmen, kriegen Sie hunderttausend Euro. Wenn Sie davor keine Lust mehr haben, weiter zu spielen, entstehen Sie einfach auf und gehen hinten durch dieses leuchtende Tor. Das sieht aus wie eine Giraffe, Sie müssen zwischen den den beiden der Giraffe durchgehen. Im Spielprinzip ist es inkludiert, dass Leute keine Lust mehr haben. Es ist vorgekommen schon. Bernd, ganz kurz, ohne zu sagen, wo du bist, sag mal kurz Hallo. Hallo. Wenn du keine Lust mehr hast, bevor du ausgewogen bist, dann melde dich kurz.
Warum ist das Teil der Show? Warum wird so viel Zeit darauf verschwenden, uns den Charakteren zu sagen, dass wir nicht Lust mehr haben? Falls wir nicht mehr weiterspielen wollen. Ja, aber warum war die erste Show schon so? Ich sag mal so, es gab Komplikationen. Falls irgendjemand aus dem Publikum keine Lust mehr hat, zuzuschauen, kurzes Handzeichen, es kommt jemand zu euch, der wird euch raus begleiten, okay? Können wir anfangen. Gut, meine Güte. Ja, vor allem, ich stelle mir das als Rettspiel vor, dann hat man diese Schattenwand.
Genau, die man auch verliert beim zweiten Mal, so ja. Wir haben die Schattenwand verloren, aber tut halt so, als würdet ihr nicht wissen, wohin der Bernd ist. Man kann das Brettspiel machen. Ich glaube, das Problem ist, dass du fünf verschiedene KIs brauchst, weil du brauchst ja es sollen nicht fünfmal dieselbe Antworten. Es sollen so kleine Generatoren sein, so Wortgeneratoren. Das können halt so witzige kleine Roboter sein, dass so halt dann irgendwie einer hat dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so einen Stock und sagt, oh, ich laufe noch mit 16-Bit, so ein alter Roboter, so irgendwie Ex halt. Aber ist nicht cooler, herauszufinden ... Weil was würdest du ... Ich fände es cool für Bernds Task wäre fast cooler, wenn er sofort erkannt werden müsste. Wenn sein Task ist, also wenn die KIs so programmiert sind, eben doch der Turing-Test. Gut, dann ändern wir das. Wir ändern die Regeln nochmal. Pass auf. Wir sind seit drei Minuten live. Ja, nee, stopp, stopp. Wie stopp, es ist live. Bernd, hör mal auf kurz. Halt die Hand vor die Kamera oder so. Bernd muss jetzt, nee, das ist besser, das ist geiler. Bernd muss jetzt möglichst so schreiben, dass er als Mensch erkannt wird, okay? Bernd, hast du noch Lust? Hast du noch Lust? Eine Runde noch. Bernd ist gegangen. Bernd ist seit drei Minuten gegangen. Verdammt noch mal. Gut, dann gehe ich jetzt auf die andere, naja, das geht auch nicht. Man weiss ja schon. Na, ich, dann, wann kommt die nächste Sendung? Fünf, fünfzig Minuten? Vier Stunden. Vier Stunden, ach Gott. Okay, alle mit dem Vornamen Stefan, gehen mal auf die Seite hier. Und alle mit dem Vornamen Markus gehen auf die. Und hier, hol mal Bernd wieder. Bernd muss raten, wer, welche Seite, ach keine Ahnung, Mann. Welche Seite, durch geschicktes Fragen herausfinden, welche Seite Stefan heißt und welche Markus heißt. Aber auch eine witzige Idee, man kann ja, das ist ja wie bei den Lego-Sets, du hast A-Set und B-Set und bei einem Brett spielst, kannst du auch dann das Brett umdrehen. Genau, das erste hat so ein Tier-Thema und das andere hat dann so ein Cowboy-Thema oder so, dann halt so der dumme Cowboy, der so ein Loch in seinen eigenen Hut geschossen hat. Ja, alle hassen das Cowboy-Thema, Freundin. Oder dann halt irgendwie der Cowboy, dem die Hose zu eng ist und der dann sagt, oh, ich komme nicht aufs Pferd, halt so kleine Witzchen. Viele Spiele haben das aber so, so B-Spiele, weil immer in jedem Brettspiel ist ein so ein Ding im Kasten, wo man nicht genau weiß, was man weder in der Anleitung findet, noch wo man genau weiß, was es ist. Ich meine, es muss doch schon mal in der Brettspielgeschichte vorgekommen sein, dass die Spielanleitung von Spiel A aus Versehen in Spiel B gelandet ist und die Familie Rödinger zu Hause sitzt, der eine Tag, wo Mama irgendwie nicht ... Papa ist seit drei Wochen trocken. Genau. Man hat mal versucht, jetzt wollte man mal die Stimmung auflockern mit einem schönen Spielabend und so und Sagerland konnte halt nicht gespielt werden. Mama hat bei ihrem Chef durchbekommen, dass sie einen Tag Urlaub bekommt, obwohl im Krankenhaus gerade die Hölle los ist. Sie hat diesen einen Abend frei bekommen und jetzt spielen sie irgendwie fünf KIs gegen Bernd und holen die Anleitung raus. Backgammon. Backgammon und da ist von Bernd die Rede und von Dynamitkarten. Jeder zieht eine Dynamitkarte im Cowboy-Setting. Und ich sag mal so, Papa wird schon nervös. Papa wird nervös. Er hat, er fingert schon hinter den Fernseher, wo er noch irgendwie eine Flasche Korn versteckt hat. Da ist noch eine Flasche Korn versteckt. Mandy, die 14-jährige Tochter, ist eh nur auf TikTok die ganze Zeit. Ja. Papa sagt, jetzt leg das doch mal weg, Mama hat nur heute Abend Zeit. Ja, dann sag ich, gib mal die Dynamitkarten jetzt aus, sagt dann Mandy. Irgendwie sind hier keine Dynamitkarten. Mama wird auch sauer schon ein bisschen. Das ist ganz komisch. Mama wird vor allem auch sauer, weil sie schon sieht, wie Papa fummelt hinterm Fernseher. Der Hund frisst den Würfel, der Hund, äh, der Hund. Ja, gut, aber von dem Würfel ist auch gar keine Rede hier in der Anleitung. Hier steht nur, dass man die Goldschürf, da hat man so eine Goldschürftablett. So, Papa, schmeißt das Brett vom Tisch gegen den Fernseher, Fernseher kippt um, hinterm Fernseher kommen ganz viele Schnapsflaschen zum Vorschein. Zerbricht, läuft in den Stromverteiler rein, Licht aus. Man, die hat das Ganze auf TikTok gefilmt, aus Versehen, weil er sich erschrocken hat, hochgeladen direkt und alle ihre Freunde sehend. Mutter ist gefeuert. Papa für den Job. Papa wird aus den anonymen Alkoholikern rausgeschmissen, weil er gesehen hat, wie er irgendwie zwei Flaschen im Korn. Er heisst Paul. Ja, weil Pauls Tochter 93 der Name der Tochter war ein grosses ... Als 15-jährige Mädchen, die sie ja lieben, sich nach ihren Vätern zu benennen. Und deswegen, wenn ihr bei MB-Spiele arbeitet, wenn ihr bei Hasbro arbeitet, wenn ihr bei Ravensburger arbeitet ... Meldet euch wegen der Bernd-Idee. Bitte bei mir, das eine, bei mir würde melden, wenn, dass ihr, weil wenn ihr falsche Anleitungen in die falschen Spiele packt, kann viel Scheiße passieren, deswegen müsst ihr irgendwie ein bisschen vorsichtig sein. Nee, kann passieren. Seid euch eurer Verantwortung bewusst. Ja, weil Brettspielabende sind einfach auch aufgeladen, immer. Ja, es ist immer so die letzte Chance, bevor man als Familie, es gibt ja Familien, die haben sich aufgegeben, und das ist oft gar nicht so schlimm. So, man läuft halt andere Wege, aber andere versuchen es noch und versuchen noch, mit einem Spieler abends noch zusammenzuhalten, aber irgendwie der 16-jährige Sohn legt nur schmutzige Wörter bei Scrabble. Machst du was mit dem Tisch? Ja, gab es doch bestimmt, oder? Furchtbar. Porno-Scrabble, ist das ein Thema? Kein Thema. Kein Thema für dich. Oh, apropos Porno. Ganz seltsam. Ich habe jetzt einen neuen Lautsprecher, einen Lautsprecher für meine neue Wohnung, und da ist auch Google, der Google Assistant drin. In den Lautsprechern schon drin? Ja, und es zieht sich durch mein Leben, dass ich immer diese Dinger mitkaufe, die ich nicht brauche. Ich will einfach nur Musik damit hören können, auf Spotify, und jetzt habe ich diesen Google Assistant. Und mit dem kann man spielen. Und zwar kann man mit dem
Akinator spielen.
Oh ja, spaßig. Die Wer bin ich,
was bin ich App, wo man herausfinden muss.
Und da habe ich mit der Freundin zusammen die Akinator App
gespielt und wir haben
an mich gedacht.
Stefan Tietze. Und haben
dann mal herausfinden wollen, ob es hinging.
Wir haben zunächst auch eine Runde mit dir gespielt. du wurdest erkannt, einmal nicht, einmal doch, ich wurde auch einmal nicht erkannt. Und dann kam es in dieser Runde, wo ich nicht erkannt wurde, war dann die Lösung, ja, der verkündete ja immer dann ganz stolz, dass er das herausgefunden hat. So, ich weiss es, der Name, an den Sie denken, ist Pornfighter Long John. Pornfighter Long John. Und du so, verdammt, ist ja gut. Also, ich habe eigentlich, das war der sehr lange Runde, war das, ich habe bestimmt 40 Fragen beantwortet. Also beim Akinator muss man immer Fragen stellen, ja, nein, und dann findet der Akinator ein Programm raus, an wen man denkt. Genau, das findet er raus, er hat als Algmus, das war er halt die besten Fragen immer stellt, wo er die meisten Leute mit ausschließt, wenn man ist, an wen man denkt, und dann kann man den Herrn Bömermann fragen und dann findet er es raus, trägt die Figur Anzug und so weiter. Und dann habe ich schon gemerkt bei trägt die Figur, ist die Figur häufig oberkörperfrei zu sehen, da habe ich schon gemerkt, es geht in die falsche Richtung. Dann ging es weiter und dann dann kam es, ich habe es herausgefunden, und wir schon so, yes, geil, war aber davor noch gesagt, aber das ist datenschutzrechtlich schwierig, da müssen sie die Familienfreigabe deaktivieren oder so was. Dann war es ja okay, und dann hat er gesagt, ja, das ist Power and Fighter Long John. Power and Fighter Long John wohnt weder in Köln, noch sieht er mir ähnlich, noch hat er irgendwas mit mir gemeint, aber anscheinend sind wir beim Akinator relativ dicht beieinander. Danach haben wir noch mal meinen Namen gespielt, und dann, die Runde war sehr kurz, und dann hat er wieder gefragt, ist diese Figur häufig mit nacktem Oberkörper zu sehen? Antwort war nein, mein, dann weiss ich's, Stefan Tietze. Ah, geil. Das heißt, immer wenn man jetzt auf dich will, muss man erst an den Pornfighter vorbei. An dem Pornfighter vorbei. Heißt, das einzige, was karrieretechnisch mich von Pornfighter Long John trennt, ist, dass er sich häufiger mit freiem Oberkörper zeigt. Meine Trichterbrust ist also der Grund, warum ich nicht in die Pornoindustrie abgebogen bin. Weil wahrscheinlich wäre es passiert. Es wirkt wie so eine Entscheidung, die ich falsch getroffen habe. Oder richtig. Aber ich dachte erst so, Pornfighter Long John ist so dein Superheldenname und dadurch wirst du entlarvt. Ist es nicht auch Clark Kent passiert in irgendeinem Comic, dass Clark Kent Akinator spielt und er dann sagt Superman und Clark Kent so nein, mega Quatsch, Clark Kent dachte ich aber nicht, Batman spielt es, sind sie Bruce Wayne, was was für ein Stoffesprogramm okay Google stopp, okay Google stopp, ach nee, das ist jetzt wo er es sagt, ihr seht euch schon du siehst schon ein bisschen aus wie Bruce Wayne so, jetzt nehmen wir mal diese Box und werfen die gegen das andere Gebäude da hinten an der Wand. Das ist immer gefährlich, das ist immer gefährlich. Und Bruce Wayne, lass es Akinato spielen und einer wird nervös. Uh, ah, das ist jetzt, ich muss. Ja, da auch so Truth or Dare oder sowas. Ja, ja. Truth or Truth. Bist du, bist du Batman? Ja. Kann ich lieber mit deiner Schwester rummachen?
Oder auch so, ja, das wäre ein bisschen unschlecht.
Comichefte, ewig aufgebaut, kämpft gegen den Schlangenmann und dann, bist du Batman?
Ja.
Gut, wer ist dran? Ich dreh die Flasche.
Miriam, uh!
Miriam, du küsst, musst den küssen, der links neben dir sitzt. Bist du Iron Man? Ja. Moment mal, sind wir hier die Avengers oder was? Ja. Jo. Jo. Jo. Ein Tag, kann mich mal einen Tag frei haben. An Arquemel hätte man es erkannt, der die ganze Zeit in der Badewanne sitzt.
Ja, der Fischgeruch ist einfach so ein bisschen der Aal.
Ist schon schwierig.
Ist Aquaman Fisch?
Jetzt hast du mich erwischt, Stefan, jetzt hast du mich tatsächlich aus dem Trockenen erwischt.
Das ist jetzt,
jetzt hast du mich.
Jetzt hast du mich am Haken.
Ja, ich bereue dich schon, die Frage gestellt zu haben.
Jetzt hast du mich im Kescher.
Jetzt kann ich nur noch zappeln.
Oh, es gibt sehr viele Fischmetaphern dafür.
Für Probleme in Problemsituationen befindlich.
Nee, da habe ich jetzt Schuppen auf den Augen.
Das ist gar nicht.
Wie viele Begriffe. Fische sind in Menschen immer so dusselige Tiere, die man offensichtlich ein Problem schafft. Ja, da bin ich jetzt dir in die Mausefalle geraten, glaube ich. Nee, du, keine Ahnung. Ich kenne mich mit Superhelden nicht aus. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das nochmal machen werde, nochmal mich in Superhelden rein, aber irgendwie, ich weiß nicht warum, ich mag keine Comics. Wie kann ich mit Comics nichts anfangen, ich weiß nicht. Ich habe nur mal Simons Comics gelesen, das ist ganz gut. Und dann hast du mir New York Green Valley empfohlen, dann kam dieser Skandal um Max Landis, dann konnte ich das nicht weiterlesen, obwohl ich es mittlerweile zu Ende gelesen habe, auch ein guter Comic. Es ist irgendwie schlechtes Omen. Ja, ich muss auch sagen, mit Max Land Land ist bei mir auch die Comicphase vorbeigegangen. Ich mochte seine Superhelden-Reihe und Green Valley fand ich toll, aber ja, das war einfach ein Vollidiot. Ja, aber ich weiss nicht, also irgendwie. Ja, ich weiss, Superhelden sind ein schwieriges Thema. Superhelden sind ein schwieriges Thema. Ich weiss nicht, irgendwie habe ich, ich bin bereit für eine nächste Phase. Ich bin jetzt so ein Stefan-Moment, irgendwie die nächste Phase, die jetzt kommt. Ja, wirklich? Ich habe diese Momente nie. Ja, ich weiß. Ich schlitter einfach rein in die nächste Phase. Du denkst immer, ich bräuchte jetzt mal ein bisschen weniger Phasen. Ja, ja. Ich habe gerade irgendwie drei Hobbys. Ich spiele die Tuba, irgendwie Stepptanz und Spanisch. Gleichzeitig, habe kaum noch Freizeit. Ja. Du bekommst ja nichts mehr. Tatsächlich, ich schlitter die nächste Phase, ich bin gerade auf dem Weg in eine Gartenphase, glaube ich. Ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen, kann ich rumpflanzen bei mir, deswegen habe ich so einen Schlitter, ich glaube ich gerade rein. Aber ich sehe die nur kommen. Ich habe noch gerade gar kein Interesse an Pflanzen, nichts, kein Interesse. Ich sehe sie nur kommen. Ich sage es jetzt, ich behaupte damit, dass ich es schon vorher sehe. Und bald wird auch wieder eine krasse Kochphase kommen, wenn man in die Küche kommt. Aber wirklich, absehbar ist es noch nicht. Ich bin mittlerweile nur so, ich kenne mich so gut, dass ich die Phasen kommen sehe, auf mich zurasen. Und kannst du dann noch Nein sagen, oder ist das wirklich wie so ein Schicksal? Nee, nee, ich bin komplett ausgeliefert, diesem Schicksal. Ich bin auch für mich okay. Muss man machen. Man sollte sich neu erfinden, aber auch bei sich bleiben. Bleib du selbst. Das ist eine der weirdesten Ratschläge, die man geben kann. Ja, genau. Vor allem, ich glaube auch nicht, dass da in dem Menschen was Gutes drinsteckt. Bleib du selbst. Bleib dir selbst treu. Hör mal auf dein Herz. Ja. Drei Tipps, mit denen ich nichts anfangen kann. Wer bin ich, was will ich und wollt ihr wirklich das, was in mir drin ist? Und auch so dieses abwechselnd, einerseits bleibt dir selbst treu, andererseits der einzige, der dir im Weg steht, bist du selbst. Ja was jetzt? Also soll ich jetzt auf mich hören oder stehe ich mir selber im Weg? Schon wieder, siehst du, du stehst schon wieder selber im treu ja aber mir treu bleiben heißt den ganzen tag nichts machen und chips essen auf dem sofa das ist das bin ich merkst du wie dich schon selber wieder dein hindernis in dein eigenes grab hindernis wovor wohin du musst auf dich selber hören du musst dir selber treu bleiben aber du hast gesagt ich soll auf dich Also ich soll nicht auf dich hören, sondern auf mich selbst. Aber du sagst, dass ich auf mich hören soll und dass ich mir selber im Weg stehe. Manchmal brauchst du jemanden von außen, der dir sagt, dass du auf dich selber hören sollst. Zwinker, hör mal auf dich selbst. Der Zwinker hat mich tatsächlich überzeugt. Ich überlege, ja, soll man von jemandem den Rat annehmen, auf sich selber zu hören. Mehr zwinkern? So in der Therapie und dann, ich weiß auch nicht, was ich Ihnen helfen kann. Ich habe jetzt noch einen Tipp. Wir sind ja seit 14 Jahren in Therapien, nichts hilft. Probieren Sie einfach mal, jeden Menschen, mit dem Sie zu tun haben, einmal anzuzwingen.
Können Sie zwinkern?
Ja, ja.
Ja, das andere Auge zwinkert sehr viel mit. Ja, ich weiß. Und diese Augenbrauen machen auch zu viel. Und dieses Mundaufreissen. Ja. Das sind verschiedene Bewegungen, die machen verschiedene Bewegungen im Gesicht. Sie machen ganz viel. Ich finde, Zwinkern ist ausschliesslich einer Menschengruppe vorbehalten, die wahnsinnig cool ist und sich selber sehr bewusst ist. Und vor allem, ich habe nicht so viel Kontrolle über meinen Körper, über mein Gesicht, dass ich plötzlich zwinkern könnte. Also ich finde, Leute, die das natürlich einfließen lassen können, sind fast Schauspieler für mich. Also Leute, die sind so sehr, können ihr Gesicht unter Kontrolle haben. Kennst du das? Nee, gar nicht. Überhaupt nicht. Aber ich muss gerade daran denken, dass wir in der Masterclass mal da fang als der Masterclass, ja ja, sollten wir damals auch so ein paar ernsthafte Berichte machen und so Leute interviewen und so. Und ich fand es immer mega langweilig, denen da echte Fragen zu stellen. Und da musste ich dieses Interview schneiden und ich dachte mir, das ist so ein Passantenumfrage, Scheiss und so. Und das war super langweilig, wäre mir egal. Aber ich habe gemerkt, dass eine Person, die ich interviewt habe, die hat mitten im Gespräch einmal so mit dem Auge gezwinkert. Aber es war nicht so Zwinker, Zwinker, sondern irgendwie so ein Tick oder so eine Zuckung, aber auch gar nicht, der Rest des Körpers hat nicht mitgespielt, sondern es war nur so ein Zwinkern, halt irgend so ein Tick oder so. Und ich dachte mir, ich höre an dem Punkt auf und lege da einfach noch so ein Bling einfach noch so drunter. Und ich fand das so witzig, dass ich es so abgegeben habe und das fand niemand witzig. Aber ich weiß noch, wie ich es so gelacht habe, weil der einfach so mit, na ich finde schon, dass gerade wenn jetzt Obama hier nach Berlin kommt, sollte man natürlich schon so ein bisschen für die sich aus. Obama in Berlin war so ein bisschen euer Go-To-Thema. Das war unser Ding. Also alles, was du sagst über Obama in Berlin. Meine gesamten journalistischen Fähigkeiten drehen sich einzig und allein darum, wie und wann und wie es funktioniert, wenn ein amerikanischer Präsident Berlin besucht. Das ist meine journalistische Ausbildung. Nee, nicht mal das konkret, Barack Obama, Barack Obama, Barack Obama. Ja, Barack Obama. Wenn Barack Obama Berlin besucht, das ist alles. Aber das ist halt schwer, wenn der Journal, was sollst du denn machen? Du kannst ja nicht die Nachrichten von vor 20 Jahren machen. Du musst halt das machen, was gerade passiert. Aber wenn während deiner Journalistenausbildung halt nur eine Sache passiert. Ja, aber war die, fang jetzt an was, ein Wochenende oder was? Ja. Nee, schon mehr, aber es passiert halt auch nicht immer was. In Berlin? Ja, ist die Stadt, die niemals schläft. Ja. Ist die Stadt, die manchmal schläft, wenn sie zu lange auf war. Ja, aber deswegen ist sie halt müde. Die sollte sich halt mal hinlegen. Die sagt Berlin, pass auf, schlaf dich mal richtig aus. Dieses immer die Nacht durchbleiben, da ist man auch irgendwann nur noch schlapp. Das stimmt. Die schlappe Stadt, man sagt ja auch Berlin die schlappe Stadt. Ja. Schlaf dich mal richtig aus. Dieses immer die Nacht durchbleiben, da ist man auch irgendwann nur noch schlapp.
Die schlappe Stadt, man sagt ja auch Berlin die schlappe Stadt.
Schlapp aber wach, halb wach.
Halb wach.
So mit einem Auge offen, mit roten Augen wach.
Mit roten Augen auf Red Bull oder Monster Energy Drink.
Ja genau, und das ist ja auch nicht gut.
Monster Energy Drink gibt es, ne?
Ja, ja.
Rockstar gibt es auch.
Magic Man, Red Bull, Booster, Relentless gibt es tatsächlich.
Eine ganz vergessene Phase unseres Podcasts.
Relentless gibt es auch von der Coca-Cola Company.
Ne, das ist mir viel zu aufdringlich.
Ist es zu Metal?
Ja.
Relentless.
Das hat ja so diese Heavy-Metal-Schrift, aber ist von Coca-Cola.
Aber Monster ja auch.
Ja, ich weiß es gar nicht.
Und Rockstar hat auch eine Heavy-Metal-Schrift. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Rockstar hat eine Hip-Hop-Schrift, aber ist von Coca-Cola. Monster ja auch. Und Rockstar hat auch eine Heavy-Metal-Schrift. Rockstar hat eine Hip-Hop-Schrift. Ich habe Energy Drinks auch noch nie hundertprozentig umrissen. Ich fand's, mein einziger Vater von Energy Drinks ist ja, dass Kinder sie nicht trinken dürfen. Aber auch hier. Gleiches wie mit meinen Putzmitteln. Ja, nee, klar. Aber dann wollen Kinder es trinken. Und ich weiß mal, dass mein Bruder mir mal eine ganze Palette Red Bull geschenkt hat. Weil der hat damals bei so einer Catering-Firma gearbeitet und so und hat halt so Events versorgt und so. Und da sind teilweise krasse Sachen übrig geblieben, halt so drei Paletten Red Bull. Und die werden halt einfach zwischen den Crew aufgeteilt. Und dann hat der mir halt seinen 15-jährigen Bruder eine eine Palette Red Bull gegeben und holy moly, da wurde nicht viel geschlafen in der Zeit. Du bist ein bisschen wie Asterix, du bist ein Kessel voll der Bullge. Und deswegen war ich seitdem, habe ich auch nie wieder eins gebraucht, weil ich einfach konstant auf einem hohen Niveau bin. Das war echt eine wilde Woche. Du hast noch nie geschlafen, oder? Ich habe seitdem nicht mehr geschlafen. Was machst du denn? Ich schaue den. Ja? Ich schaue in den Mond. Oh, das ist zunehmender Mond. Kann man sich merken, je nachdem, wohin die Schale offen ist. Man kann sich merken, mit einem Z wird zunehmend in der alten Schreibweise. Kennt ihr doch, wie man eine Schreibschrift geschrieben hat? Eine Z? Das macht man ja erst so einen Halbmond. Was? Du vielleicht nicht. Als ich damals Schreibschrift gelernt habe, habe ich das auch schon nicht gelernt. Ja. Ich meine, das Z, was man lernt, eine Schreibschrift, ist so ein umgedreht, ist wie so ein D, grosses D. Und das kommt vom Mond, oder was? Nein. Nein, nein. Warte mal kurz. Und wenn du das A machst, machst du es andersrum. Das kleine A machst du ja erst den. Für aufgehender Mond. Genau. Jetzt gibt es ja abnehmender und zunehmender Mond. Oh Gott, jetzt ist alles durcheinander mit aufgehender Mond. Es gibt abnehmender und zunehmender Mond. Aufgehender und zurückgehender Mond. Nicht aufgehender, nein, abnehmend und zunehmend. Ach so. Nicht zurückgehend, oh Gott, du machst das ganze Sprichwort komplex. Und jetzt, du kannst sehen, ob der sehen, ob der zunimmt oder abnimmt, je nachdem, ob es Z oder A, wo die Beugung ist.
Ich mal's euch auf.
Aber mit aufgehend und zusammenfallend.
Aufgehend und zurückgehend.
Zusammenfallend.
Zuklappend.
Okay, ja, ist doch nützlich zu wissen, wie der Mond funktioniert.
Jetzt weisst du, ob er
zunimmt oder abnimmt. Heute haben wir
zunehmenden Mond.
Ich bin ja immer
so ein bisschen, so ein Augenmerk auf so
esoterische Sachen. Ich finde das einerseits
faszinierend,
weil es so bescheuert ist.
Und es hat auch mal einer in der Arbeit gesagt,
bei Rocket Beans, ich sag nicht wer,
und er meint dann so, oh, gestern war wieder Vollmond, da kann ich immer nicht schlafen. Ja, das sagen viele. Und ich habe gesagt, Sekunde, du meinst, du kannst nicht schlafen, weil dein Zimmer so hell ist, wegen des Vollmonds. Nee, nee, ich habe immer die Rollos zu, aber ich kann trotzdem nicht schlafen, wenn Vollmond ist. Er hat gesagt, komm, das ist doch Bullshit, das muss doch, also das, wie soll das passieren? Das sagen viele. Und er meinte so, nee, nee, ich meine das schon ernst. Und ich dachte mir das, du bist ein erwachsener Mensch, was soll das sein, soll das die Anziehungskraft sein? Und danach habe ich es mir zur Aufgabe gemacht, immer wenn Vollmond war, wollte ich den am nächsten Tag fragen, und, wirst du geschlafen? Gut, aha. In der Hoffnung ist er es mal vergisst. Genau, dass es vergisst und nicht in einem Bullshit-Corde, habe ich aber nie daran gedacht, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich habe immer deswegen, habe ich tatsächlich eine Zeit lang mal immer mir Vollmond geguckt, wann ist Vollmond und war aber nie da zu der richtigen Zeit bei Rocket Beans in den nächsten Fall. Vollmond ist wirklich im Sinn. Das ist doch Bullshit, wie kann man das, also ich meine, das ist ja irgendwie so eine Magiesache dann, dass bei Vollmond dann irgendwie die Geister und bla. Ich meine, es kann natürlich schon sein, oder es ist halt so eine Self-Fulling Prophecy, aber irgendwie muss sich da noch ein Mysterium lösen. Ich würde gerne mal kurz recherchieren, weil ... Das ist Bullshit. Ich kann ja andere Zusammenhänge haben. Ja, welche denn? Wegen der Schwerkraft oder was? Dass die dich aus deinem Bett rauszieht, dass du selbst die Flut in deinem Bett bist und dann kannst du nicht schlafen oder was? Nee, eher, dass wenn der Mond so steht, dass die Sonne ihn vollkommen anstrahlt, dass dann die Konstellation befindet sich heraus. Dass der Mond, Ebbe und Flut bewirkt, ist wissenschaftlich eindeutig bewiesen. Viele Menschen glauben jedoch auch an weniger anerkannte, ich finde es gut, dass es direkt mit einem Fact reingeht, das hätte ich von solchen Seiten schon mal nicht gedacht. Viele Menschen glauben jedoch auch an weniger anerkannte Wirkungen des Mondes. So sollen die Mondphasen etwa die Ernte oder das Wachstum der Haare beeinflussen. Besonders um den Vollmond ranken sich zahlreiche Mythen. Man denke nur an den schlafwandelnde und mondsüchtig bezeichneten Menschen. Bla bla bla. Werwolf? Man denkt nur an den Werwolf oder an den Werpinguin, wie wir ihn begründet haben.
Einflussun unwahrscheinlich. Gut. Die zusammengefassten Ergebnisse dieser Schüttel darauf hängen, dass Menschen in Nächten rund um Vollmond nicht kürzer schlafen als rund um Neumann. Zudem schienen die Testpersonen bei Vollmond auch nicht mehr Zeit zum Einschlafen zu benötigen. Sehr gut. Endlich mal Ergebnisse aus einem Schlaflabor, die wirklich nützlich sind. Wir geben in Deutschland Milliarden Euro jedes Jahr aus für Schlafexperimente, Schlaflabors. Und nichts ist da rausgekommen. Ja, man soll nicht zu spät ins Bett gehen und man soll keinen Kaffee mehr davor trinken. Okay, aber weiter, ich will mehr Fakten. Warum kommt da nichts?
Ich kann mich nach einem Kaffee trinken und mich direkt danach hinterlegen und schlafen. Ich bin das Gegenteil, ich bin so anfällig auf Koffein. Ich auch. Ich darf nach 15 Uhr keine Mate mehr trinken, sonst bin ich raus. Ich kann nicht schlafen. Und da, apropos, da sind wir wieder bei Energy Drink, dürfen Kinder nicht trinken, da habe ich ihnen eine Mate gekauft im Supermarkt und habe es auf die Kasse gelegt und dann hat hinter mir Mutter und Kind und dann ist auch wieder so eine Situation, die wir letzte Woche angesprochen haben, meinte dann das Kind so, ah, guck mal, Mate, ab welchem Alter dürfen Kinder Mate trinken? Und es war auch so ein, wo die Mutter einfach so komplett ... Bin ich jetzt in das Strafgesetzbuch, soll ich mir jetzt ... Sehe ich aus wie ein Richter, was soll hier geschehen? Ich bin nicht die perfekte Mutter, okay? Ich habe nicht die Antworten auf alle Fragen. Und die dann so ... Du hast ja eine Autorität, und das ist ja auch geil, weil du kannst jetzt einfach was sagen. Du kannst jetzt sagen 16 und das Kind wird ein paar Jahre lang denken, ich darf keine Mate trinken. Und die Mutter hat gesagt, naja, so ab 14 halt. Oh, das klingt plausibel. Das ist so eine gute Antwort, so dieses ... Das Wort Halt würde bei Antworten auch immer so ein bisschen ... Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ja, wurde ja erst 1997 aus dem Grundgesetz. eine gute Antwort, so dieses Das Wort Halt würde da bei Antworten auch immer
so ein bisschen auf, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wurde ja erst 1997 aus dem
Grundgesetz gestrichen, die Würde des Menschen
ist halt unantastbar.
Wurde ja dann erstmal revidiert,
wo man gesagt hat,
das klingt wiederum mega,
das klingt fast noch selbstbewusster.
Die Würde des Menschen
ist halt unantastbar. Das klingt fast
ohne Scheiss, ohne Scheiss.
Das ist eine ganz andere Bedeutung als. Die Würde des Menschen ist halt unantastbar. Das klingt fast ohne Scheiss. Das ist eine ganz andere Bedeutung als die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar halt. Das ist was ganz anderes. Das klingt viel unsicherer. Aber die Würde des Menschen ist halt unantastbar, finde ich viel selbstbewusster. Ohne Scheiss, ja, deal with it. Das ist viel mehr in Stein gemeißelt jetzt. Ohne Scheiss, lass uns bitte dafür sorgen, dass das erste, also ich meine, da haben wir uns jetzt einen Paragraphen ausgesucht, der mit am schwierigsten ist zu ändern. Ich glaube, man muss erstmal alle anderen von hinten aufrollen und alle anderen korrigieren, bevor man an denen ran darf. Das ist wie so ein Superlevel und das ist der Endgegner. Ey, ich finde das so wichtig, ohne Scheiss, dass wir da rausmachen. Weil jetzt nennt man Abtönungspartikel diese Wörter, ja, halt, und die sind in Deutschland, ist eine der wenigen Sprachen, die diese Wörter überhaupt haben. Ich finde es total klasse, mit denen was zu machen, unter anderem bei unserem wichtigsten Artikel, denn die Würde des Menschen ist halt unantastbar. Ja, das klingt total, ja, okay, was will ich machen? Genau, das klingt so, damit kann man die Diskussion beenden. Ja, jetzt ist ja vorbei, die ist halt unantastbar. Ja, gut. Ja, die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar, das kann auch eine Frage sein. Die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar? Kannst du das Frage stellen? Die Würde des Menschen ist halt unantastbar? Kannst du nicht das Frage stellen? Ey, mal Frage an die Juristen da draußen, wie viele Fragezeichen gibt es im Grundgesetz? Gibt es da Fragen? Keine einzige. Nicht mal im Vorwort.
Doch im Vorwort ist es glaube ich ausschließlich aus rhetorischen Fragen. Haben Sie sich schon mal gefragt, wo Sie nachlesen? Hinten der Klappentext ist auch die ganze Zeit. Wo würden Sie nachgucken, wenn Sie nach dem Gesetz gucken wollen? Kurntgesetz erste Seite, kennen Sie das? Sie wollen frei in einem Land leben? Na dann haben wir was für Sie. Ich habe neulich mit einem Richter gesprochen und ich habe immer, ich habe versucht, Smalltalk zu halten und eigentlich war was immer ein, können Sie mir das raten, was raten Sie mir dazu und er hat immer gesagt, da muss ich nachschlagen, keine Ahnung. Ich fände es so toll, mit dem Richter zu sprechen, privat. Das hat mich damals so wütend gemacht in Wirtschaft und Recht, dass die hat mich die Lehrende gefragt, ja, was ist Paragraf 136? Ich habe gesagt, ihr könnt doch nicht ernsthaft von mir erwarten, dass ich Paragraphen auswendig lehre, nicht mal Juristen lernen Paragraphen auswendig. Und sie so, nee, es gibt dieses Buch, da kann man nachgucken. Ich habe Juristen verwendet? Ja, sie hat nie,, nee, ich hab, ich weiss selber gar nicht, wer, nee, nee, nee gesagt hat gerade. Egal, auf jeden Fall, hab ich damals schon gesagt, gut, da war ich auch ein rebellischer 15-Jähriger gesagt, nee, das ist unsinnig. Voll auf Mate. Voll, vier Kästen, rennt Bull into, sagt, nein, ich guck das nicht nach, das steht in dem Buch drin. Schweiß, tropft er von der Stirn. Nee, aber es stimmt eigentlich. Die müsste man ändern. Das ist das Erste, was ich machen würde, wenn ich präsentiere. Das ist die Podcast UFO Challenge. Wir ändern den ersten ... Merkel, wie heißt das? Erster Artikel des Grundgesetzes, oder? Ja, ich glaube, das kriegen wir hin. Damals, als wir versucht haben, Caps Lock abzuschaffen, nichts. Als wir versucht haben, den Stegosaurus als Emoji zu etablieren, nichts. Als wir versucht haben, die WC-Ente zum WC-Schwanz umzubenennen, gar nichts. Zumindest das Design zu ändern, wieder nichts. Wir schiffen nichts. Wenn wir jetzt den ersten Artikel des Grundgesetzbuches ändern, hallo die Waldfee. Das wäre was. Das wäre mal eine Schlagzeile. Ich glaube, das brauchen wir auch. Das wäre eine Schlagzeile. Naja. Das wäre aber monatelang Schlagzeile. Meinst du, das wäre so ein Thema? Wenn da halt die Würde des Menden ist halt unantastbar. Ja, weiß ich nicht genau. Und ich wäre auch für Ausrufezeichen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wie viele Ausrufezeichen gibt es? Gibt es Punkt, Punkt, Punkte, die wir im Grundgesetz so auslaufen lassen? Wann glaubst du, gibt es das erste Emoji im Grundgesetz? Oh ja, oh ja. Das wäre vielleicht realistisch. In Finnland oder sowas haben die bestimmt ja schon. Ja, bestimmt. Ein so cooles. Ja, ja. Aber das finde ich, ich finde ja geil, man kann ja runterhandeln. Also unsere erste Forderung ist, die Würde des Menschen ist halt unantastbar Ausrufezeichen. Ja. Und dann lassen wir uns erstmal vom Ausrufezeichen abbringen. Ja, absolut. Aber wir sind bereit, das einzugestehen. Das ist für uns schon ein Riesenproblem. So, dann machen wir auch einen Terz. Aber dann werden die sagen, okay, dann das Halt kriegt er. Aber was sind die nächsten Schritte? Umfrage? Ne, Petition. Ja, meine ich ja. Erst mal Petition. Das eine ist eine Frage, eine Umfrage. Ja, aber ich meine die Petition. Erst machen wir ein Doodle, wann die meisten Bock hätten, die Umfrage zu starten. Genau, wir machen ein Doodle, wann die meisten Leute Bock hätten, die Petition zu unterschreiben. Und dann machen wir eine Petition, ob wir nicht was anderes als Doodle benutzen sollten, sondern ein anderes Organisationstool. Dann schaffen wir erstmal Doodle ab. Ja, Doodle muss weg, muss von dem Erdboden verschwinden. Wir werden nicht fortfahren, bevor nicht Doodle weg ist. Und dann geht es weiter mit Basecamp oder Slack oder so und dann fangen wir richtig an. Was ist Spacecamp? Wir hatten damals, um nochmal auf die Frank-Elsa-Masw zurückzukommen, wir hatten jede Woche ein anderes Organisationstool. Es war wirklich lächerlich ab einem gewissen Punkt, weil wir immer up to date und der neueste heisse Scheiss sein wollten. Und dann war immer wirklich so, jetzt benutzen wir alle Base Camp, jetzt benutzen wir alle Trello, jetzt benutzen wir alle Google Docs. Ehrlich gesagt, bei Trello habe ich im Moment, wo ich es installiert habe, weil Leute ... Es haben mir vier, fünf Leute gesagt, du brauchst das Trello.
Ich habe es mit so einem Grinsen widerwillig gemacht.
Ich wusste, aus Trello wird nichts. Und?
Nichts gegen Trello, das kann man bestimmt gut einsetzen. Aber ich habe es kennengelernt als einfach überflüssig,
einfach weil man schon ein anderes System hat.
Wenn man nur Trello benutzt, ist das bestimmt toll, aber so ist es nervig.
Und es geht einfach immer noch weiter, weil esclass ist dann zu einer Firma geworden und dann hieß es auch so in der Rundmail, wir benutzen jetzt den ersten Blockchain-Kommunikationstool und so. Ich dachte, okay, gut, die Firmenphilosophie wurde eingehalten, immer das neueste Tool, wo wir sich alle eingelernt haben, dann zu sagen, nee, wir wechseln jetzt. Wo ist die Firma jetzt? Auf dem Mond. Nee, das ist tatsächlich recht erfolgreich. Hat sich am Ende dann doch gelohnt, glaube ich, aber das war einfach toll. Aber allein die eigenen Emojis machen zu können bei Slack ist schon cool. Das ist schon witzig. Das sind Dinge, die mich überzeugen. Ich habe gestern geträumt, in einem Orchester zu spielen. Welches Instrument? Weiß ich nicht mehr. Wie? Weil der Traum geht weiter, weil es war spannender, was, wo wir gespielt haben. Und zwar haben wir für eine Alienrasse gespielt. Der Traum war zweigeteilt. Der Traum war erst Alien-Invasion, super schrecklich, viele Menschen sterben, Städte waren kahl komplett. Ich habe so ein bisschen die Corona-Krise auf mich selber verarbeitet, quasi. Ich habe in meiner Wohnung gesessen, rausgeguckt und alles war leer gefegt und so. Dann waren irgendwann, liefen so Aliens rum, war wahnsinnig gruselig, hatte wahnsinnig Angst vor dem Traum. Und dann war mein harter Cut und dann war ich, hatte so einen feinen Swirn an und habe in einem Sein in einem Orchester gespielt für die Alienrasse.
Und dann hab ich mir wirklich ... und da muss man mal sagen, wie genial ist denn ein Traum. Bitte. Den Cut finde ich faszinierend, weil einerseits würde ich mir denken, ich würde gerne erleben, was da passiert, aber andererseits eigentlich auch nicht, weil eigentlich kann man auch mal einfach einen Cut machen in so einer Geschichte und sagen, so jetzt spielt mal was. Ja, so, und dann gab's zwei Orchester.
So, es war ein grosser Kreis quasi in so einem weird und sagen, so, jetzt spielt mal was. Ja, und dann gab's zwei Orchester.
Es war ein grosser Kreis quasi in so einer weirden Felswelt,
so Avatar-artig.
Und dann war ein grosser Kreis,
und auf der einen Seite war im Halbmond unser Orchester,
das Erdling-Orchester, auf der anderen Seite war das Alien-Orchester.
Ach so, es gab keine Zuschauer.
Nee, keine Zuschauer, die Orchester waren die jeweiligen Zuschauer.
Und dann waren erst wir dran und haben Beethoven gespielt oder so was.
Vielen Dank. Das war das Alien-Orchester. Ach so, gab keine Zuschauer? Nee, keine Zuschauer. Die Orchester waren die jeweiligen Zuschauer. Und dann waren erst wir dran und haben irgendwie Beethoven gespielt oder sowas. Pause, kein Applaus, nix. Und dann kam das andere Orchester. Und dann habe ich wirklich, ich habe eine Symphonie, in der ich neun bis zwölf Minuten lang Alien-Musik geträumt. Wirklich Alien-Musik? Naja, deren Orchester, die hat auch andere Instrumente und so. Du hast das wirklich gehört im Traum? Ja. Hast du davon noch irgendwas behalten können? Eine Melodie, irgendwas? Gar nichts? Okay. Aber es war schön, es war nicht irgendwie fremdartig oder so, es war schon schön. Die hatten auch schöne Sachen an, aber halt nicht so wie wir. Es war so ein bisschen Battle of the Bands, aber zwischen zwei Orchestern. Battle of the Orchestras in the in the Universe. Aber ohne Publikum. Galactic Battle of the Orchestras. Gibt es eigentlich Battle of the Bands bei Orchestras so? In der Rechnecke! Das Orchester aus Prag. Ja, ja. Gegen London Philharmonics. Dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam. Ich finde es immer so faszinierend, wie kreativ Träume sind. Zum Beispiel hat mir jetzt ein Kollege, hat er einen Ohrwurm von Who Needs the Quickie Mart? Eine berühmte Musicalnummer, wo Apu singt, weil von einem grossen Unternehmen wird ihm der Quickie Mart Rack genommen und er rechtfertigt sich das in der Musicalnummer, dass er den Quickie Mart gar nicht braucht. Und er hat mir diese Musical-Nummer nacherzählt. Und seitdem habe ich auch irgendwie dieses Album, davon habe ich aber noch nie diese Musical-Nummer gesehen, mittlerweile schon, aber so ewige Monate lang habe ich das nicht geguckt, weil wir es nicht gefunden haben bei YouTube auch. Und dann habe ich dann irgendwann das geträumt. Ich habe diese gesamte Nummer geträumt. Als Simpsons. Als Simpsons. Mein Traum war diese Musical-Nummer der Simpsons. Wie Apu singt, Who Needs the quickie mart? und er fühlt sich dann schlecht und blablabla. Halt so was auch passieren könnte. Ich denke mir einfach so, hat der da nur die normalsten Träume reingeschrieben oder warum hat dann niemand den Quickie-Mart-Traum? Stell dir mal so ein Werk, so wie die Traumbedeutung, ein Freuds einziger Patient an den Quickie-Mart-Traum und er analysiert den dann. Von den Simpsons geträumt. Von den Simpsons. Aber es ist ja wirklich schwer zu analysieren, wenn Leute so ganz spezielle Sachen träumen, was man dann dazu sagen kann. Aber ich meine, das ist in den heutigen Medien, vielleicht sind solche Dinge überhaupt nicht mehr anwendbar. Wenn du halt einfach ultra spezielle Sachen, du lebst ja in deiner eigenen Welt. Ich liebe die speziellen Träume. Ich mag es tatsächlich eigentlich nicht so gern, wenn ein Podcast über Träume erzählt wird und so, weil es immer so maximal absurd ist. Aber einen möchte ich noch erzählen kurz, weil der fand ich sehr spannend. Und da möchte ich mir gerne mal deine freudsche Traumdeutung haben. Du bist ja Schüler von Lacan, also kannst du gerne, hat der auch Träume gedeutet eigentlich? Ja, aber so funktioniert es nicht, dass man das einfach sagen kann, nachdem man einen Traum gehört hat. Ja, schon klar. Aber ich würde gerne, diesen einen Traum fand ich nämlich wirklich faszinierend. Es ging darum, ich war auf einer Art so eine Messe.
Es war so eine, aber wie so ein, am Ende wurde auch... Ich glaube, Stefan, ich glaube, du bist schwul.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Okay, also...
Also das ist, also so viel weiß ich.
Messe? Also so viel
steht sicher. Okay, also es war
eine grosse Messe und am Ende wurde auch
der bekannteste,
der beste Stand sozusagen bewertet. Der Welt der Messen. Naja, das war nicht so und dann ging es darum, man hat quasi aber so, jeder hatte dann so eine kleine Mini-Welt, wo ganz viele Menschen auch drin gewohnt haben, also wie so ein Modellbau. Jeder hatte einen Stand und jeder hatte seine eigene kleine Welt gebaut. Mit kleinen Menschen.
Mit kleinen Menschen, die darin gelebt haben.
Aber du warst normal gross.
Ich war normal gross.
Ich war in der Messe.
Und dann habe ich halt in meinem kleinen Stand, war dann so ein grosser Tisch aufgebaut, wie so ein Modell, wie so ein Modelltisch, so ein Eisenbahnding.
Und da haben halt ganz viele kleine Menschen drin gewohnt in meiner Stadt.
Und bei allen Leuten auf diesem Stand, das war wie so eine kleine Messe, sondern eher ein Wettbewerb, wer die coolste kleine Stadt hat. Und bei allen waren die so wuselig und auch laut. Da hat man auch die Städte immer gehört. Oh jetzt, der Judge kommt gleich. Exakt. Und bei mir kam dann die Jury hin und bei mir war es komplett still, die Stadt war komplett leer und dann waren die Dördungs auch so, wo sind die jetzt? Und dann gab es aber ein kleines Stadion bei mir und die ganze Stadt saß im Stadion, Hände auf den Knien und haben komplett emotionslos still alle nach vorne geguckt. Ich fand das unglaublich gruselig, weil meine Stadt so weird war. Weil die haben auf mich gehört, weil die haben gesagt, die Jury kommt jetzt. Die ganze Stadt saß da im Stadion, hat einfach die Hände auf, also so ganz völlig abstinent, mit leeren Augen haben die einfach nach vorne gestarrt, keine Emotionen gezeigt.
Das war nicht gruselig.
Und dann bin ich danach in so einen Laden gegangen, wo man sich so Erweiterungen kaufen kann.
Da kann man sich dann so eine Bar kaufen, kann man dann da reinstellen in die Stadt.
Die sind fertig ausgerüstet und so.
Und dann beziehen diese Menschen das auch.
War ein bisschen wie Downsizing eigentlich.
Dann war ich dann da und dann war da so eine junge Verkäuferin und die hat gesagt, boah, ich glaub, du gewinnst. Und dann hab ich gesagt, danke. Und dann hab ich dir eine Bar gekauft und hab die da reingesandt. Was ein seltsamer Traum. Aber wie geil diese Welt ist. Aber ja, coole Welt eigentlich. Was eine coole Welt. Das könnte eine gute Kurzgeschichte sein. Das stimmt. Aber die Frage ist halt immer so, jetzt spielen wir wieder unser altes Spiel, aus wessen Perspektive?
Aus wessen Perspektive, wissend nicht, aus welcher Perspektive finden wir es raus.
Heute bei uns zu Gast Stefan Tietze mit folgender Frage.
Wir haben eine kleine Miniaturwelt, die in einer Messe antreten muss gegen andere Miniaturwelten.
Aus wessen Perspektive wird diese Geschichte erzählt?
Ich glaube, Dorfbewohner.
Kind. Das erste Kind, was da aufgewachsen ist in dieser Welt, was nicht gekauft wurde und da reingesetzt wurde, das erste in der Welt gezeugte Kind. Während der Zeremonie, während der die Stadt gewinnt den Preis. Und die Stadt ist ganz aufgeregt, weil die Stadt freut sich auch, dass sie gewonnen hat. Aber weiss das Kind, dass es in der Miniaturwelt lebt oder ist das Verheilung? Sehr große Twister am Ende. Okay, also alle anderen wissen, dass sie in der Miniaturwelt leben, also so ein bisschen Truman Show mässig und nur dieses eine Kind weiss aber nicht, dass es eine Miniaturwelt ist. Genau. Gut, und dann, wer ist dann der, der immer sagt, jetzt ruhig bleiben, jetzt kommt der Judge, so eine Art Gott oder was? Ja, so eine Art Gott. Und dann müssen alle irgendwas machen? Ja, alle müssen sich ins Stadion setzen. Weirde Religion, aber gut.
Ich habe mich so ein bisschen, ja, weird, aber ich habe mich so ein bisschen gedeutet damit, dass es so Kontrollverlustängste sind und ich am liebsten meine Umfeld so behandeln wollen würde, dass alle genau so umhören. Ja. Ich hätte ja meistens eine Kontrolle. Ja, das ist immer so ein bisschen wie wenn bei Lehrern dann so der Prüfer kommt oder so, bei Lehrern dann irgendwie so, ja da kommt jetzt jemand, der bewertet den Unterricht und so. Und dann normalerweise absolute Chaosklasse, aber diese eine Klasse ist einfach perfekt, alle brav melden sich und so. Zeigen auf, sind leise. Und das ist eigentlich der Deal, der Pakt mit dem Lehrer. Ihr dürft immer scheiße sein, solange in dieser einen Stunde. Prüfer müssen ein ganz seltsames Bild haben von Schülern. Bei allen Prüfern ist man ja cool. Niemand hat ja Bock dann vor so einem Prüfer, der irgendwie aus dem Regierungsbezirk Arnsberg bei uns immer kam, um dann zuzugucken beim Unterricht. Da wolltest du ja nicht dann irgendwie auffallen oder sowas. Indurch haben sie alle benommen. Und dann so Klassendurchschnitt 5,3, Körperverletzung, mehrere Schwangerschaften schon in der Klasse und dann gehst du da hin und alle so im Anzug. Guten Tag, kann ich Ihnen in den Stuhl reichen, bitte schön. Mit Kaffee vielleicht. Patrick, möchtest du kurz sagen, wo im Buch wir waren? Klar, selbstverständlich, wir waren auch der Dank für die Frage erstmal. Er ist einbezogen, ich werde da nicht so oft einbezogen, bin ja gerade auch jemand, der sich auch gerne mal zurückzieht, deswegen vielen Dank für diese Aufforderung. Wir waren in einem Buch auf Seite 67 tatsächlich. Okay, ich finde es toll, dass du auch gesagt hast, wie du dich dabei fühlst, falls du irgendwie noch Probleme hast damit, wie es im Unterricht ist. Das kannst du gerne nach der Stunde noch mal zu mir vorbeikommen. Das Angebot würde ich sehr gerne annehmen, das habe ich von keinem anderen Lehrer bisgang wahrgenommen. Ach, das ist doch das Mindeste. Ihr wisst doch, dass mir das auch wichtig ist, dass wir hier alle nicht nur lernen, sondern auch eine ... Sie sehen übrigens fantastisch aus, Frau Gemmaßbach. Dankeschön, das ist sehr, sehr nett. Gut, die binomische Zahl ist neun. Das war's für heute. Wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder, bis dahin, macht's gut, ciao! Dankeschön, danke, ach, das wäre doch nicht ... Ach, ist das ein Kuchen? Ach, nicht, doch wie ich Geburtstag bin, auch dreistimmig. Happy Birthday to you. Mama Spaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa Also muss ich... Nervlich. Ich fand sie nervig. Also, ich fand die wirklich scheiße. Ich fand die wirklich richtig... Grauenvoll. Die sind ja gar nicht mehr wie Kinder. Die haben ja nicht mehr gesprochen wie Kinder. Die Uboe war komplett verstimmt. Der Einsatz kam zu spät. Also das ist... Und Happy Birthday im Gedo habe ich jetzt auch noch nicht gehört. Ja, und abgesehen davon hatte heute niemand Geburtstag. Gute Frage übrigens von niemandem, aber die Beantwortete wurde im Internet war, was ist der Ton zwischen Du und Moll?
Der einzige Unterschied zwischen Moll- und Du-Akkord ist ja die kleine Terz versus die große Terz. Aber es sind ja sehr menschengemachte Intervalle. You know?
Na ja.
Das heißt, du kannst da einfach ...
Ja, na klar.
Aber du hast jetzt meinetwegen, ah, das ist irgendwie 440 Hertz oder sowas.
Und so weiter.
Das heißt, du kannst einfach ... Ja, na klar. Aber du hast jetzt meinetwegen, ah, das ist irgendwie 440 Hertz oder so was. Und so weiter. Du kannst ja, wenn du eine Terz spielst, kannst du ja einfach auch die mittlere Terz nehmen. Zwischen der kleinen Terz und der großen Terz ist ja noch ein Ton. Den gibt's zwar nicht auf dem Keyboard, den gibt's ja keinen Ton dazwischen, das ist ja ein Halbtonschritt. Aber den gibt's ja in echt, weil du hast ja alle Wellenlängen der Welt. Das ist ja alle Frequenzen gibt's ja. Kannst du einfach den mittleren Ton nehmen, ob was das für ein Akkord ist. Stell dir raus, der ist super hässlich. Du, Stefan, du lernst Tuba, du kannst das gerne spielen und damit schmeißen wir euch raus. Ich möchte gerne Challenge, grosse Bullshit-Challenge, bringt diesen Funfact, den niemand interessiert, mal irgendwo ein.
Ich weiss gar nicht, was der Funfact ist, einfach, dass Töte, die nicht auf dem Klavier sind, schlecht klingen.
Da wäre man auch selber drauf gekommen.
Ja, genau.
Ich meine, du kannst ja auch eine Geige zum Beispiel, hast du ja keine Bünde, der kannst ja spielen, was du willst. Schon vorbei die Folge.
Ich geb den Tod, wie!
Ja, ist schon lange vorbei, schon abmoderiert.
It's a Voice-Bird-Production.
Ja, ist es auch.